think like it would have been special
it's kind of like the way i feel about
terminator 2. like i love the theatrical
version so much and that's one of my
favorite movies of all time and then
when i saw the special edition i'm like
oh my god i liked it even more now yeah
and that's kind of what this scene does
for me like is it needed and maybe not
necessarily but would it add absolutely
[Music]
oh buddy
the code it's been deciphered
at
reddit
[Music]
because i'm batman
all right guys looks like we got our
official joker scene released uh this is
a deleted scene from the movie the
batman featuring barry ko gaga matt
reeves has talked extensively about this
particular scene it's like five minutes
long i'm excited to see it if you guys
can leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated check out all the batman
coverage you've had over the past month
let's get into action people
dog
oh
[Music]
[Music]
press
isn't it
almost our anniversary there's a serial
killer
i want your respect
first anniversary
paper
what makes you think i'm so cheap
i thought you'd be curious
why it's so cute you think i cut off in
this stuff
don't you
you're pictures
let's chew his fingernails off
oh it's sinister
i love the way they're shooting this
violence
he likes little puzzles doesn't he
so meticulous
i keep it planning this at
life
i know who he is
framing
yeah
he's a nobody
wants to be somebody
the mayor
[Applause]
the commissioner
yeah
he's got ambition
you think his motive is political oh no
this is very very personal oh my god so
silence of the lambs i love it yes these
people have all wronged him
probably goes way back
unhealed wounds stolen much money
why is he writing to me
maybe
he's a fan of yours
good call
or maybe he's got a grudge against you
too
[Music]
maybe you're the main course
any theories
not yet really
but something is different
this time
this is very upsetting to you let's get
back to him
you are so much more fun
to talk about me what are you here to
talk about i want to know how he thinks
you know exactly how he thinks have you
read this file
back and forth solid man
into
[Music]
makes you look soft
i'm wasting my time
okay
i'll tell you what i really think
[Music]
i think
you don't really care about his motives
whether he loves or hates you
i think somewhere deep down
you're just terrified
because you're not sure anyone huh
you think they deserve it
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[ __ ] love that scene a brilliantly
shot scene that's one of the best
deleted scenes i've ever seen yeah
that's not i don't mean that in any
hyperbolic way that is legit one of the
best deleted scenes i've ever seen
that's like his own little short film
right there it's like a batman fan film
that some youtuber was like barry kogan
should have gotten his own movie or
something so i'm gonna make a fan film
out of it and it feels that way i'm
trying to think what scene this would
have come after if that makes sense like
what is the placement of the scene after
and before i think this really would
have complemented the film quite well
especially for when he actually does
encounter riddler and discovers that a
lot of what joker was alluding to was
actually correct i love all the signs of
the lambs types of vibes that this was
omitting throughout i do think though
that this scene in like an extended cut
would definitely complement the film and
really work because a lot of times you
watch these deleted scenes you're like
they're not really necessary however i
think it would actually elevate the
scene in a lot of ways i get for runtime
how you could have asked it not gonna
lie like i could see why it wasn't
necessary to be in the movie but i do
love the world building it does i do
love that line about like the
anniversary establishing where it's at i
love the way it's shot where it's he's
always obscured only captured in these
like minimalistic reflections and and
the close-ups that are so disgustingly
morbid intimate but john what'd you
think of like barry coken's performance
oh i i loved it man and it's funny
because in the dialogue there's so many
little uh things that you could take as
nods to previous iconic joker lines and
yeah like now post heath ledger
especially i think there's that kind of
albatross of like are they just gonna go
for that or they gonna do their own
thing and i really really liked what he
did here and i liked the sort of koi
quality that he played it with this sort
of almost flirting with batman you know
he's he's they said he's a proto version
he's not the joker that we know just yet
and i get that sense while also feeling
you know obviously when that smile comes
up that grin and just certain of the
jabs that he's giving to him like you
get that quintessential you know yin to
the yang and yeah barry kogan i mean i i
really like the sort of slow draw like i
want to go back and re-listen to the
scene because there are certain lines
that almost get sort of fuzzed out in
the just tone
and the eerie intimacy that is happening
it's so funny because like this barrier
of the glass is such a presence in and
of itself and it's always you know
obscuring like you said his face or it's
always you know out of focus or
something like that they make you
imagine what the front half of his head
looks like by showing you the back of it
showing you his hands and his
fingernails and like all the mutilation
that this guy has gone through and and
yeah i really like that sort of seething
it's like a calm chaos almost eerie
because you can imagine what a maniacal
more fully powered joker would be like
and at this moment though i really love
that rapport between him is like yeah
you know you clearly put me here i know
you and i have a fixation on you but
yeah i'll take a look at your little
file whatever i feel like yeah this is a
scene that would have certainly
complemented the movie and maybe just
you know would have needed like a third
piece or something to make it fully
rounded i mean i love just the way that
he's kind of predicting the whole thing
and maybe that was a fact or two maybe
they're like well he's just gonna be
right by the end so maybe we don't want
to foreshadow that all directly too soon
but um i i got such a huge kick out of
their back and forth and i mean you know
pattinson is it's just like this is the
most consistent performance because i
felt like i was just back in the theater
watching the movie again true i think
thematically though it complements it
exceptionally well by every time you get
to the end of the batman and then you
know one of riddler's goons is saying
i'm vengeance and batman's realizing
like this is the product of him like
batman has helped inspire this and the
way how ridler saw a reflection of
himself within batman joker has a line
in there where he's telling batman that
part of you thinks he maybe he was right
and that little extra umph probably
would have
helped elevate the movie a little bit
more even though i think the movie's
like pretty great i'm like oh that would
have just given me that extra little
nudge that i didn't think i wanted or
needed but i i think like it just would
have been special it's kind of like the
way i feel about terminator 2 like i
love the theatrical version so much and
that's one of my favorite movies of all
time and then when i saw the special
edition i'm like oh my god i liked it
even more now yeah and that's kind of
what this scene does for me like is it
needed and maybe not necessarily but
would it add absolutely well and this
one it's funny because of the you know
great people have had about the ending
scene with the joker this doesn't feel
at all tacked on like it absolutely
feels like a scene that would have
flowed probably pretty would have made
it better yeah yeah and to me it feels
like it probably happened pretty early
on you know maybe after that first
investigation of the mayor's mayors of
the da's apartment with the police and
all that stuff well yeah i think a lot
of people felt the same way and how that
joker scene and the theatrical felt cut
felt tacked on whereas here it would
have actually made it feel more natural
like the setup that you're building to
when they do cross paths would have been
like an oh [ __ ] like you already know
it's the joker right when he starts
talking as opposed to the movie and the
theatrical version making it feel like
we're about to reveal to you it's the
joker but if the joker's already
established in the movie and then you
see that he's familiar with his work
actually seeing the crime scene photos
getting acquainted and like really
understanding who riddler is it it adds
more tension to it in the sense of joker
then when he is befriending him at the
end of the batman movie he's like oh i
can manipulate this guy because i know
who he is already yeah it completes it
yeah so then it makes for a good setup
for part two even though matt reeves
said he doesn't know if the joker's
gonna be the main villain in the batman
too i think it would be a better setup
for it and uh yeah i like the eeriness
to this but guys what did you think
about it i thought barry kogan did a
great job i still want to see him like
more but from what we got it does feel
like inspire from other things it's like
i've seen so many different joker
interpretations as many of you have it
feels like a bit of a combination of
what heath ledger did combined with the
i don't remember which one came first
either jerome or jeremiah but whatever
the second one the latter one is in
gotham
that um my god that beautiful actor
cameron monahan played in gotham it
feels like a combination of of those two
to me but also with the messed up makeup
is especially feeling like actually both
of the versions that uh freaking
cameraman had played alright guys leave
your thoughts down below thank you so
much for being here subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and hey let's
do it
daniel gallagher daniel my friend look
we've made so many jokes about you
working as a pharmacist and i do want to
say that if you want to get a promotion
you got to work at an insane asylum man
look at all the amounts of prescription
you would be dishing out left and right
to all kinds of crazy people and knowing
the kind of crazy people that are here
in the world of arkham oh man you become
influenced you need some medication that
medication would stop working and then
you would eventually need actual help
yourself you'd be an inmate and my god
the amount of friends you would make i
know you're a big batman fan but come on
man life can get a little dull if you're
doing the same thing over and over again
it's time to get a little nuts so get a
little nuts with some of the people that
you're helping
[Music]